today on the matt walsh show time
magazine takes virtue signaling to a
whole new level by using and promoting
so-called neo pronouns at the same time
they're also promoting a pornographic
children's book which is the real story
we'll discuss also the white house
declares that half of the country are a
dangerous extremist a threat to
democracy and should be incinerated in a
missile strike paraphrasing slightly an
important daily wire report reveals just
who is benefiting from student loan
forgiveness
winnie the pooh gets the horror movie
treatment and a duke volleyball player
says she was the victim of racist
harassment during a game you'll never
guess what happens next actually you
will all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
roe v wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally not over but
rather leaving dc and going to the
grassroots no group in america is better
positioned than 40 days for life with
about 1 million volunteers in a thousand
cities 40 days for life holds peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities they
have a larger presence in blue states
with california being their largest
state where they're most needed some
former abortion facility directors say
that these vigils can cause the abortion
no show rate to go as high as 75 percent
which is detrimental to their abortion
business to say the least these
law-abiding vigils have closed many
abortion businesses in america and
nearly half of those closed abortion
facilities were in liberal cities where
abortion will remain legal including san
francisco chicago and seattle 40 days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and minds in the grassroots to end
abortion you can check out their
locations their podcast and their free
magazine at 40daysforlife.com
and it's so important that you do that
because what we know is that the fight
for life
is certainly not over at all it is in
many ways uh well it's certainly
entering a new phase a very important
phase if you want more information on
this go to 40 days for life uh on four
days for life go to 40daysforlife.com
you know when i was a kid my two younger
sisters used to sometimes speak to each
other in a secret language they had made
up they claimed that they had invented a
whole new dialect with its own unique
words and sentence structures and rules
of grammar it was pretty clear to me at
the time even more clear to me now
looking back in hindsight that they were
just babbling gibberish to each other
and primarily doing it to annoy me and
they succeeded
and i sometimes reflect on those more
innocent times and and
i think about how my annoyance would
have turned into crushing despair had i
known
what sort of world i would find myself
in as an adult if only i had known that
i would one day live in a society where
lots of people have invented their own
secret gibberish languages and that we
would all be expected to listen to this
gobbledygook and take it seriously and
even speak it ourselves
i i think if someone had told me that
or told me like anything else about
modern society i would have simply
gotten on a boat and set sail into the
pacific
and found a remote island somewhere far
away and isolated
and lived out the rest of my days there
in fact this is an option that i'm still
actively considering even now especially
after seeing things like this time
magazine
attempting to win the nobel prize in
virtue signaling
published an interview last night with
the author of a pornography book called
genderqueer and we'll have more on that
book later on but
they tweeted a link to the article with
this caption
this is what it says
time spoke to genderqueer author and
illustrator maya kobe on about about air
work the efforts to restrict access to
air writing
and what a make of the current cultural
moment
now those aren't typos though it would
be impossible to tell if they were
these are rather the pronouns that the
author maya identifies as
this is made clear in the article itself
reading just a small portion of it it
says maya kobe felt a wave of relief on
tuesday morning waking up on the west
coast and early morning peak at emails
revealed a virginia court had dismissed
a lawsuit seeking to label kobabe's book
genderqueer as obscene and restricted
sale to minors in virginia
the suit was among the latest in an
onslaught of challenges to kobabe's
memoir which was the most challenged
book of 2021 according to the american
library association in the 2019
illustrated graphic memoir kobabe who
uses e m air pronouns
explores air process of coming out as
non-binary and asexual cobab33 isn't the
only author to face serious new
challenges to air material according to
research by pen america a non-profit
organization to advocate for free
expression
1145 books by 874 different authors were
banned from school libraries and
classrooms between july 1st 2021 and
march 31st 2022. in the wake of kobe's
win in virginia time spoke with the
author and illustrator about air work
the efforts to restrict access to air
writing and what a makes of the current
cultural moment now
it may sound like uh a
spelled e y would be like the fonz's
personal pronoun but the fonz lived
before our society had one big
collective stroke and started babbling
nonsensically to each other
these are rather non-binary pronouns uh
so-called neo pronouns which is to say
that they are words
maya simply invented in her troubled
head and now demands we all use in
reference to her the argument often put
forward in defense of neo pronouns is
that
although they're made up
well so is every other word in the
english language
this is this this same talking point has
been trotted out today by those looking
to defend time magazine but
of course it isn't true
the english language is learned
not made up
as far as you're concerned okay you
didn't invent the english language
neither did i we don't leave children
alone to come up with their own words
for everything and then slap the label
of english onto whatever they come up
with
we teach them what words are and what
they mean
now it's true obviously that every word
we speak was at some point in the past
formulated right it made up if that's
how you want to put it but
this follows a logical process
and the words all mean something and
that meaning is understood and shared by
everyone who speaks the language these
are the two ironclad rules of language
it must mean something to be a word and
it must be shared it must be a shared
meaning
if i if either two of these rules are
not followed you don't have a language
you have gibberish
and by insisting that each person can
simply come up with their own words and
that those words
don't need to really mean anything at
all
the left is not proposing changes to the
english language
neither are they helping it to evolve
they are instead destroying it breaking
it down demolishing it
which is what they do to literally
everything
i mean look at it like this
the sentence please pass the salt
contains four words
now
each of those words came into being at
some point in the past
they weren't invented by one single
identifiable person
okay but but rather they they formed and
evolved in a logical and understandable
way there's a whole field of study
called etymology which examines exactly
this process of linguistic evolution
but if i were to one day simply decide
that instead of saying please pass the
salt i am going to say gabaguda flabadi
everyone else at the dinner table would
look at me confused and assume that i'm
either demonically possessed or
attempting a very bad impression of a
90's era adam sandler
that's because i cannot just decide on
my own to replace existing words with
with words that have logical
etymological or origins with random
sounds that i came up with that's not
how language works
and yet even this example at the dinner
table does not capture the absurdity of
the left's pronoun nonsense because at
least in the case of the dinner table i
can tell you what my gibberish means it
means past the salt
but the person with the neopronoun can't
explain what it means because it means
nothing
what does it mean to be an em heir what
is that nobody can tell us nobody can
explain it
because it's simply nonsense it's
nonsense all the way down it's nonsense
on top of nonsense on top of nonsense
and when you get to the bottom of the
stack of nonsense you find nothing
you're just hovering in in abyss
it is a made up word
which symbolizes
nothing nothing that is other than the
overwhelming narcissism of the
individual who uses it
i mean whatever else the non-binary
binary person quote-unquote claims to be
communicating with her pronouns what
she's really conveying
is that she is pretentious
and self-absorbed in the extreme that's
what all of these pronouns really mean
it means i am incredibly incredibly
self-absorbed
now there may be something else going on
here too as i was thinking about it it's
possible
that part of the strategy with the neo
pronoun
is to make the left's other attempts at
language manipulation seem less extreme
by comparison right maybe they're
pretending to try to get us to use e m
air or z zem zebra or whatever so that
we'll throw up our hands and agree to
call a man she or a woman he so long as
they just leave it at that
now maybe that's the idea because like
in in reality
no one is actually going to use those
pronouns no one no normal person nobody
is going to go around saying em air no
one's gonna do that and they must know
that no one's going to do it so maybe
part of the idea is all right well if
you won't do this
then at least do the other the this
other pronoun stuff
my kids sometimes use a similar strategy
you know they'll come up and say hey
daddy uh can you buy us a grenade
launcher
what no i can't i can't okay well then
can we just have ice cream at least
and this might be part of the idea
though i may be doing the left an
undeserved favor by assuming that
they're as clever as you know my
nine-year-olds
and yet
we've been so hung up on
the gibberish
that we haven't even discussed the book
that this person wrote and that might be
another part of the plan here
this is the book that time magazine is
promoting
that book genderqueer
is a work of outright pornography
with content so explicit and outrageous
that i ca i can't show it to you and i
can't even describe it
to you
suffice it to say that there are
explicit images of various sex acts
along with scenes so depraved that you
you couldn't even anticipate them
so if you're imagining like what what a
pornographic book might consist of yeah
it consists of a lot of that kind of
stuff but then also stuff that you
wouldn't even think of like just one
example which fair warning this is
highly disgusting and disturbing so but
this is one that i will describe to you
there is one scene
in which the author depicts a
conversation with her sister
where the sister suggests that she
tastes her own vaginal discharge
and then we're shown a panel with her
finger covered in that discharge now i
told you it's disgusting
but at the same time as much as we want
to cover our ears and say i don't even
want to hear about this
these are the books they're putting in
schools they're putting these in schools
for little kids to read
and what i just described to you is one
of the less graphic moments of the book
it's
like one of the only moments i could
even describe
putting it in schools across the country
for kids
and and when normal decent people
object to this sort of content being
used to educate children
the left cries out in horror claiming
censorship and fascism if you don't want
explicit pornography taught to your kid
in school like it's literature
then you're a fascist
now all in all
this whole story perfectly encapsulates
our cultural moment the entire thing
from the pronouns down to the book right
because it's inane nonsense on the
surface that's the e m air pronouns
nonsense on the surface and then when
you look beneath the surface what you
find is vile hideous evil filth
now the good news if we can
call it good news if there can be any
good news
is that the nonsense is so nonsensical
and the hideous evil is so hideous and
so evil that the left is forcing people
to finally make a choice
like there is no neutral ground anymore
that time has long since passed
are you going to run around babbling
absolute gibberish
at the behest of narcissists intoxicated
by the stench of their own farts are you
going to do that are you actually going
are you willing to do that
even if up until this moment you were
the sort of person who said i just want
to be polite and i want to get along
with you and it doesn't hurt me if they
want me to use the pronoun
really yeah i mean it doesn't physically
actually it would physically pain me to
use those pronouns in a non-ironic way
but maybe it wouldn't physically hurt
you yet are you really going to do that
are you going to keep a spreadsheet
maybe carry a clipboard around with a
spreadsheet keeping track of all the
gibberish words that each person that
you know each egomaniacal narcissist you
know demands you use and before you
refer to them or about them uh you know
refer to that clipart are you going to
do that
are you going to tolerate literal
pornography being taught as literature
to children in school
or are you going to finally draw the
line
and say no more
i've had enough
this is it
no
you can cry about it
okay you can say your feelings are hurt
you can call me a bigot i don't care the
answer is no stop talking
stop demanding no
are you gonna say that
that's the choice they're forcing
it's a it's a time of deciding
i know what my answer is
you have to decide what yours is
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
have you been dreading looking at your
401k or ioa ira account balance you're
not alone but what if i told you that
you could build a financial bunker that
grows and protects your money during
even the worst economic times the bank
on your self-retirement plan alternative
lets you escape the financial carnage
plaguing our economy and has never had a
losing year in over 160 years whether
you've been investing for years if
you're just starting out now's the time
to bypass wall street and bank on
yourself bank on yourself helps you
reach your financial goals without
unnecessary risks you get guaranteed
predictable growth and retirement income
without any luck or guess work this
strategy also lets you take a tax free
retirement income to protect you from
the coming tax tsunami so all those 87
000 ira agents can't get their filthy
hands on it unlike a government control
401 k or ira you control the money in
your plan use your money with no
questions asked without disrupting your
savings growth and your plan doesn't go
backward when the markets tumble get a
free report with all the details of how
adding bank on yourself to your
financial plan can help you take back
control of your money just go to
bankonyourself.com walsh that's
bankonyself.com
walsh this information is for education
purposes only is not a solicitation for
the purchase of any financial product
all guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurers
okay we begin
with everyone's favorite white house
press secretary karen gene pair
daily wire reports white house press
secretary karen jean pair appeared to
admit that president joe biden counts
everyday americans among those who
constitute the extremist threat that he
has repeatedly railed against uh these
are also the people that joe biden has
threatened to blow up with fighter jets
and has actually um
on multiple occasions made this threat
during wednesday's press briefing jean
pair told real clear politics philip
wegman that biden was concerned about an
extreme portion of the country and she
said that this was not limited to only
those in positions of leadership within
the republican party we have that clip
for you here it is
for folks sitting at home
when the president is talking about
preserving the soul of the nation and
his threats to democracy he's not
referring to those individuals he's
talking about republican leadership
well let me be be very clear it's not
just republican leadership it's not just
that blanket right he is talking about
an ex in an extreme portion like extreme
uh part of of the party he's been very
very clear about that he was just in
maryland as you all know
and he talked about governor
larry hogan and talked about how he is a
conservative republican who does not who
is not in that bucket right he was very
clear and he he was very purposeful in
saying that and being respectful to a
conservative republican who are not part
of that extreme
so again want to be very clear here
this is not a blanket statement
this is calling out what we have seen
for some time
[Music]
since 2017 as the president wrote about
in his article right when you are when
you are supporting an authoritarian
figure as we have seen who is leading
currently leading the former uh the
former president uh
you know and and um and saying that
inciting the violence that you are or
wanting to take away our freedoms
you know
we need to say something he's not going
to shy away from that
okay so the maga republicans are
extremists
a threat to democracy taking away
people's three freedoms just by voting
you're you're a threat to democracy
voting is a threat to democracy
now what we have to understand of course
is that when she says maga republicans
um
ultra maga you know radical maga
whatever term they're they they decide
to use today
they're not
talking about
exclusively
uh
fanatical fans of donald trump that's
not what they're referring to now if
that was what they referred to it would
still be wrong to call those individuals
uh
extremists and threats of democracy this
would still be a horrible thing for her
to be saying
but it would be a much smaller group
than what she's actually referring to
because according to biden and the white
house and really any democrat any
leftist there are as she described there
there are larry hogan republicans okay
you're like larry hogan in maryland
you're that kind of republican
conservative or you're a mega republican
that's it you fall into those two
categories well
there are
i don't know
10 or 11 larry hogan republicans in the
country
and the only reason a guy like larry
hogan gets elected there is because
there are just no other options if you
are a republican in that state
and given that it's a blue state he's
the only kind of guy that can actually
get elected there so so uh
there's that
or you're a mega republican
and you could be a mag of republican
doesn't matter how you feel about donald
trump all that means is that you are
actually another way of putting it what
she's actually a conservative if you're
actually a conservative and you believe
the things that you say then you're a
mega republican i
i certainly would fall into this i i'm
definitely would be included as a as
right as an extremist threat to
democracy i've been told this many times
i'm a terrorist i'm a sacastic terrorist
i'm a maggot republican
meanwhile
you know i'm critical of them try to
criticize them all the time i'm very
open about the fact i i want i want
desantis in 2024 not donald trump
if we can't have desantis if donald
trump is that ends up being the nominee
then i'll vote for him over the democrat
of course but
i'm i'm openly advocating for somebody
else
ron desantis
still a mega republican fine
we're all extremists threats to
democracy so this is she says it's it's
not a blanket statement it's not a
blanket statement it's just a statement
that applies to
tens of millions of people in the
country
that's that's all it is it's not a
blanket statement i'm just
you know writing off like half of the
country at least
as extremists and threats to democracy
this is a very
to put up mildly concerning moment in
history i used
the phrase a few days ago
to describe a similar situation as
pre-pre-genocidal and i really mean that
this is these are
the kinds of language the kind of
language that they're using the things
that they're saying
this is pre-genocide talk
it is it's the kind of thing you say
before you start rounding people up
and so we have seen this escalation
and it has it has taken on a new
urgency and severity over the last even
just the last couple of months
now we have the white house saying half
the country are extremist threats
democracy
uh as we talked about on backstage last
night if you watched that show if you
didn't watch you can go to youtube or
dailywire.com and watch the episode
which was one of my one of my favorite
backstages by the way so you should
watch we talked about yesterday that
you know uh ben shapiro
at the podcast movement conference his
very presence your your your presence
is harmful to people not your
opinions not even that that'd be bad
enough to say your opinions are harmful
your presence your physical presence
well how do you solve that if somebody's
pre how do you solve
somebody's presence
and then of course we've also been told
especially the last couple of weeks that
you're that we're terrorists
by simply not even presenting opinions
but by
talking about things they don't want us
to talk about presenting facts that they
wish were not facts or at least wish
nobody knew about we are terrorists
your presence is a threat you're you're
you're an extremist threat by voting for
the candidates that you like you're
terrorist
and there's something else i want you to
think about too that i that i also
brought up on backstage yesterday
there is i think quite intentionally
here a self-fulfilling prophecy
uh
they keep calling us radical dangerous
violent none of those words apply it's
not true
but they want it to apply
they're trying to provoke it
um
and the thing is using these words about
people if you when you when you
label entire groups this way and start
talking about them like they're
dangerous like they're worthless
like they're very presence is a problem
that needs to be solved that has a
radicalizing effect on people
and then you add to that because the
other part of this story here is while
we're all being labeled and dismissed
and talked about like we're
uh
you know terrorists and criminals
on the other hand of the spectrum there
is an increasing lack of accountability
now there is just
no accountability at all
we find about people on the other side
is they can simply say and do anything
they want i know you might say well
that's been the case for a long time i
think it's it's yes
but it's even more the case now than
than it was in the past it's worse now
than it's ever been it seems to me
um if you're on the left you just do
whatever you want say whatever you want
no accountability
that also has a radicalizing effect on
the other side because people become
desperate
when you see the the powers that be
doing whatever they want
um acting
lawlessly if they want
no accountability
makes people desperate they don't know
what to do
and then when they're being labeled this
way it makes them angry angry desperate
marginalized
it leads to a uh
a potentially volatile situation which
is exactly what these people want by the
way
all right this was good from an nbc
reporter kat tenbarge is her name
uh i just wanted to mention this briefly
she tweeted
more people need to be talking about
jackson mississippi
the city ran out of bottled water to
give residents yesterday it's the
largest city in mississippi it's 80
black their water system is failing
because of years of neglect this is
environmental racism
now the situation that she's talking
about is true and it's a terrible
situation
jackson mississippi is one of the many
municipalities in our country that's
falling apart at the seams
being
horrifically mismanaged
people are suffering because of it she
says it's racism
that's interesting i went and as other
people have done i went and and i wanted
to see like who are the racist people
running this
this town
and and who have you know are neglecting
the water system and and people are
suffering who are these racist people so
i i went and i found um well racist
number one is of course the mayor he's
running the city
and his name by the way is chokwe antar
now
it may surprise you to learn that is not
the name of a white person
the mayor is a black guy
but i went and looked at the city
council maybe that's where all the races
are there are seven people on city
council four of them are black majority
black
in fact if you go down the jackson
mississippi
uh government and you look at people in
positions of power
it is
uh predominantly black
and so it's a little bit hard to blame
racism on this and and also by the way
of course and this is the most important
aspect they're all democrats
i mean all these cities are being all
being run by democrats
um
many of them have city governments that
are
you know have a have a heavy minority
presence
a lot of these racist police departments
are have black uh police chiefs
so it would seem that we need an
explanation beyond anti-black racism
especially because it's not like the
democrats just took over yesterday
and it's not like they just started
electing minorities to leave these
cities yesterday no it's been the case
for a long time and yet these problems
are worse than they've ever been in many
cases
no it's not here's what it is it's not
racism let me try to help you out cat
tim barge
racism is not the issue
there is an issue and you've pointed to
it
in jackson mississippi the issue with
the water it is a it is not racism but
rather a universal disregard for the
well-being of human beings
and that disregard they are they are
very equitable
by the democrats that are running these
cities are quite equitable in their
disregard because they apply to
everybody
now they might talk about different
groups differently
but uh they actually have a disregard
for the well-being of everyone they
don't care
they don't care because they're corrupt
they're power hungry they're not there
to help anyone that's not what they care
about
and also they're beholden to
their religion the religion of leftism
um which keeps them firmly implanted in
a in a fantasy world not in reality and
when you live in a fantasy world you
cannot solve practical problems in the
real world
this is one of the reasons why these
cities are falling apart because they
are plagued by practical problems when i
say practical problems i mean just real
problems things that are really
happening to people
that would have potential solutions but
the solutions are also practical
they're not solutions that you can solve
by simply talking about it or writing
dissertations
writing a thesis
studying about it at college you can't
solve it that way
to solve it by doing things but they
don't they don't
that requires you to live in reality and
they don't
so that's the issue just so you know
uh luke rosiak over at the daily wire
has
i think a really important report here
about the student loan so-called student
loan forgiveness plan and who actually
benefits from it
so here's what he reports
the vast majority of student loans are
racked up by people in elite professions
like medicine and law who spend years in
school before being rewarded with high
paying jobs a daily wire analysis of
department of education data shows
a smaller component component is
billions of dollars in loans to people
with less marketable degrees who
incurred debt that amount to a bad
investment such as 100 million dollars a
year in loans for gender and ethnic
studies
[Laughter]
i didn't even realize it was that much i
mean i've been saying this whole time
that the student loan forgiveness is
like we're taken from plumbers and
electricians and car mechanics and given
the money to gender studies majors i
didn't realize how true that actually
was a hundred million a year just in
gender and ethnic studies loans
um
this leaves them with salaries that are
unable to pay for the loans the data
suggests that president joe biden's plan
to forgive student loans amounts to a
subsidy primarily to doctors and lawyers
and secondarily to people who acquired
knowledge and skills that are not in
demand
so this is the majority of student loans
vast majority
um
belong to people
who
who work in professions that are
that reward them with very high salaries
so it is in some ways even worse than
yeah we're taking from the plumbers
electricians car mechanics blue collar
people and giving to gender studies
majors
that's bad enough
but at least the gender studies majors
most of them are unemployed thank god
um not that they deserve to be given
anybody's money
even worse is like you're also giving to
people who have jobs and are and are
doing quite well in those jobs
the data suggests that president joe
biden's plan to forgive student loans
amounts to a subsidy primarily to
doctors and lawyers okay um
it says quote the bottom line is that
this move is a massive debt transfer
from those who took out student loans
onto those who chose not to or could not
attend college
biden said he will cancel up to twenty
thousand dollars in student debt for
those who had received pell grants and
as much as ten thousand dollars for
borrowers who make up to uh make under
125 000 per year or 250 000 for married
couples this would include many doctors
who often spend their early career as
low paid residents on the way to earning
big bucks
and even by the way making 125 000
that's the cutoff now
if they actually were focused
only on poor and middle-income people
then that's where the cutoff would be
right they'd put the cutoff at fifty
thousand dollars a year forty thousand
whatever thirty thousand
um
if you're making 125 000 a year as a
single individual
meaning you don't have kids or
dependents or anything
you're doing very well
now that's
how well you're doing is going to depend
on where you live but really no matter
where you live if it's just you making
100 you're making six figures
and we're giving ten thousand dollars to
those people
i mean if you're making six figures by
yourself with with no one else to take
care of
and you don't have a lot of money in the
bank in savings then that's on you i
mean you you are catastrophically
irresponsible
and you don't deserve a dime from
anybody else
um
and then it goes on for that i would
just go and read the report because it
lays out uh
you know the the field of study
the total annual federal loans
uh annual loan per person there's a
chart here and it goes through that and
you see very clearly that the vast
majority of the loans again are to
people in these kinds of high-paying
professions
and they're going to get this loan
forgiveness
this is why it's so important um
when we talk about this issue
you know we want to talk about the facts
and we want to be very logical
and we also want to deliver the harsh
truth which i am always very willing to
do
the harsh truth is that you made a
decision you signed to the dotted line
and and uh
you should be the one who has to
has to deal with that and that's it's
your burden to carry
i'm sorry you have to carry it but it is
your burden so that's that's the
that's the harsh truth and we need to
deliver that
but i also think we we cannot neglect
neglect the compassionate argument
i think this is this is a a mistake that
we make on the right i certainly make it
all the time
where we sort of
skip over that they say well who cares
about that let's talk about logic and
facts let's get down to the let's get
down to brass tacks here
no because then we're kind of seeding
that we're surrendering that it's as if
oh well they have a compassion on their
side we have logic and facts we do have
logic effects we also have compassion
though
because our position is the more
compassionate position
on really every topic including this one
because
uh my position on student loan
forgiveness so-called the reason that
i'm against it
it has to do with the facts it has to do
with logic it has to do with
uh the harsh reality and that you have
to face it
but it's it's also in
a moral position that i've taken
and that a lot of us have taken it's a
compassionate position
i have compassion for
the
blue-collar workers who didn't go to
college didn't incur that debt but but
probably have plenty of other debt that
they're dealing with mortgages and car
payments and everything else and who
knows what else uh you know medical
bills
and who now are being given the burden
to support people who are way better off
than they are so i have compassion for
them it's part of the reason i'm taking
this position that's that the rest of us
have
and we can't neglect that i think we
have to be very clear about that
here's an interesting report from new
york post says twitter was ready to
start selling only fan style porn
subscriptions in a bid to boost its
revenue but put the feature on ice
earlier this year due to concerns about
child porn according to a new report the
social media site uh allows users to
post porn but gives them no way to
monetize it twitter created and
considered launching an only fans like
subscription feature that would let
pornstar sell nude photos and videos so
they were gonna
they were gonna put only if they were
gonna combine basically only fans on
twitter
and put it right on your feed if you're
on twitter
the decision would have been
controversial and risked alienating
advertisers but could also have helped
twitter differentiate itself from other
social media sites
how so we're going to differentiate
ourselves from other social media sites
by being even more pornographic than all
the other ones
that that's that's really that's unique
there's a unique strategy
oh you know what we're going to do this
is this is the brain trust over over
twitter i have an idea this is how we're
gonna set ourselves apart listen to this
okay
listen
we're gonna have raunchy stuff
can you believe it no one's thought of
that on the internet yet that's what
we're gonna do
in april twitter assembled an 84-person
red team to pressure test the decision
to allow adult creators to monetize on
the platform
by specifically focusing on what it
would look like for twitter to do this
safely and responsibly
the team
how are we going to profit off of smud
how are we going to profit off of
hardcore porn
safely and responsibly
the team reportedly found a slate of
disturbing holes in the twitter's
twitter's plan including that the site
is unable to consistently detect and
take down non-consensual and child porn
the red team reportedly wrote twitter
cannot accurately detect child sexual
exploitation and non-consensual nudity
at scale
launching a porn subscription service
would make the risks worse the red team
reportedly found because smut sellers
would be incentivized to flood the
platform and uh much of the porn would
be hidden behind a pay wall the red team
also reportedly warned that adding more
porn to the site would lead to scrutiny
from lawmakers and it would annoy
long-time users
now there's a couple of points here
worth making
one is that um
you know twitter
encountered
a fact which is that
when you open the floodgates to
pornography
um a lot of child pornography and non
and non-consensual pornography otherwise
known as rape
which is what all child pornography also
is
that is all going to you open the
floodgates all that rushes in
it all comes hand in hand you cannot
separate it
which is one of the arguments i have
always made
for restricting pornography across the
board and across the entire internet
there are other arguments you can make
for it
that i've articulated and others have
articulated but
this is one of them
that this all goes hand in hand
and as long as you have this
laissez-faire
attitude about it and you say i just say
whatever leave all the porn alone
the more porn sites the better
no restrictions in place
right pornhub it's just there anyone can
access it
nothing stopping anyone
as long as you do that you are providing
cover
to
child pornographers
i mean the only way
to actually seriously battle child
pornography
and suppress it get rid of it punish it
is to
you know
uh apply that attitude to all
pornography
you know it's to take a much
stricter approach to all pornography
it's the only way to do it
but then the other point here too is
that uh
the youngest age allowed on twitter i
believe is 13. that's that's their
at least
you know if they changed it recently i
don't know
but for a long time anyway
i think it's still the case that's what
their terms of service say youngest age
allowed is 13. now they're obviously
kids that are younger that are on the
platform anyway but that's what they
that's what they specifically allow 13
year olds
so you have to ask yourself
why are they allowing pornography on the
site at all when you know
and have specifically allowed kids to
use it
and not only do you allow it but you're
you're trying to think of ways to get
more porn on the site
and the only reason you stopped yourself
is because of the child porn problem
and the only reason that that stopped
you probably was just because of the
legal implications of that
sorry that's a question we should be
asking why why
why have pornography at all on a
platform that kids are using
yet another argument for restricting
this stuff we've just gotten used to
this we've gotten accustomed to it like
it's normal or it should be
that on the same platforms that kids use
just throw pornography on there too
making no attempt to protect the kids
from it none
that's why it's always absurd you hear
the argument from the porn apologists
and they say oh you know this is it's
always there's always been porn in the
world and
you know back in the day
kids could look at a playboy magazine
well it certainly wasn't nearly as
readily available
they were not being exposed to it at
nearly so young in age
and if they were exposed to it it was
not going to be nearly as depraved and
disgusting and traumatizing
as what kids are routinely exposed to
now
but also
there were rules in place like you you
couldn't a kid
yeah maybe at a gas station would have a
porn magazine on the on the rack and
it'd be you know in plastic on the back
of the rack
um
but it was expected of the gas station
the attendant if a kid takes the poor
magazine off the rack and goes up to pay
for he's going to be stopped from doing
so
now is that going to prevent him from
ever seeing porn again no but
there there are laws
there are basic laws in place and
regulations to put some kind of
protection
some kind of insulation
and now with internet porn there's
nothing
there are there's basically no laws no
regulations nothing at all no attempt
even
to protect kids from it
that's why i i have no patience for the
people who say well we can't there's no
way to protect kids
we haven't even tried so you're we
you're saying let's not even try it's
not worth the effort
and and what is the downside of trying
if you were to at least before we get
into
stricter policies or banning porn before
we even get there
but what about just requiring that porn
sites all of them verify ages
and not just by clicking something but
actually verify it
photo id credit card something there are
ways to do this
what about that
what is the argument against that that
wouldn't stop every kid from ever seeing
porn again it would act it would at
least put some sort of insulation there
it would put some barrier protection
it's something at least and it would
protect at least some kids some of the
times and that's worth doing what's the
argument against it the argument is that
well it's inconvenient for me the
argument the only arg the only argument
is from the porn user that that uh he
doesn't want to be inconvenienced by
that
i just want to have immediate access to
all the point i want i mean i don't want
to put anything in between me and the
porn
so your ease of access to pornography
not being inconvenienced
is worth exposing millions of kids to
hardcore pornography every single day
it's a
it's a indefensible argument it really
is
all right speaking of indefensible last
thing here winnie the pooh entered the
public domain recently and so a
filmmaker came along and scooped it up
and turned it into a slasher horror
flick because this is i don't know how
all the laws here work exactly but it's
in the public public domain so they can
at least
make a movie with winnie the pooh
apparently there's there's still some
copyright things like they couldn't give
him his trademark red
uh shirt so they put him in a flannel
instead um but anyway
the trailer for this winnie the pooh
horror film was just released let's
watch a little bit of that
you know you're the first person i've
ever shown this place to and why am i so
special because soon will be christopher
mary robin
we should be close now we're not going
to find them we will
pooh piglet
eeyore we were friends for many years
and they're out there
christopher
we need to leave
now i really need to find out what's
happening here okay
you know
i i wanted to most people are having fun
with this i wanted to laugh at it
but
i actually kind of hate it i i mean it's
not serious it's not meant to be taken
seriously i i assume it's supposed to be
basically a joke
although it is a real movie that's
coming out
but i kind of hate it because
just everything about childhood is being
perverted and destroyed it's all
corrupted and now they're doing this to
winnie the pooh
i mean not winnie
not not the poo first they got poo
scheissd now they got winnie all the
poos are going down
and
i so i i don't have the appetite for it
or the or the it's like that not the
right frame of mind because because of
the the cultural context which
everything is being taken away
from from children everything is
becoming this also means it's not really
funny because this is like all childhood
everything associated with childhood has
been corrupted and they've done this
with everything so it's not even novel
anymore
and the last
whatever last
remaining
innocent bits of childhood there are
just like leave them alone and by the
way
i'm not saying that they're destroying
my childhood because that annoys me when
adults say that
when something like this happens or
there's some some new version of a show
that they liked when they were kids
comes out oh you're destroying my
childhood
no it's not your childhood your
childhood is over my childhood's been
over for almost two decades so i'm not
worried about my childhood being
destroyed my childhood already happened
and it was not destroyed i'm worried
about
my children's childhood currently being
destroyed that's the issue
so leave winnie the pooh alone
damn you
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
testing scams also known as smishing
that's not what they're known i'm not
calling them that no one is calls them
that i never heard anyone say smishing
a mashup of sms and phishing smishing
scammers send you enticing or alarming
smishing messages oh my gosh i've been
smished
now the best thing you can do when
you're getting smished best thing you do
is receive one of these fake messages if
you're receiving is to block the sender
so you don't get smished anymore it's
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft and smishing are
affecting our lives your personal
information gets exposed to things like
smishing so often that it's dangerously
easy for a cyber criminal to smish your
identity completely protect your
identity and you can do that easily with
lifelock by norton lifelock detects and
alerts you to potential identity threats
that you may not spot on your own such
as
smishing if you do become a victim of
identity theft a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist will work to fix
it nobody can prevent all identity theft
or all smishing or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
lifelock identity theft protection
starts here join now and save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off smishing
michelle says okay matt you have to tell
me what you were talking about at the
beginning of your members block
yesterday the segment started with you
in the middle of a conversation with
sean all we heard was that you were in
someone's house and afraid they might
murder you
uh yeah well these are the kinds of
conversations that you miss out on
if you're not a daily wire member and
thus cannot watch the members block
of the show which by the way uh you
definitely want to watch the members
black text we have a special guest on uh
on with us so
uh
you want to watch it i i will okay uh
here's what i was here's what i was
briefly telling you before we went on
the air and then partially when we were
still on the air here's what it was
referring to a couple of uh days ago
i
uh i rented a u-haul after work and i
when i drove down to someone's house to
pick up a couch that my wife had bought
like a used couch
because
um
i'm not gonna pay full price for
furniture that's an insane thing to do
there's no reason to do it
and i in the difference in price
sometimes what's up with something like
a leather couch the difference you're
talking about a difference in like five
thousand dollars potentially
so we found this uh she found this
really nice couch and so i just you know
got i got the u-haul
and i
drove down to pick it up
i didn't even really think about it
until i was in you all driving down and
i thought
i don't know if i'm not sure if this is
the kind of thing i can do anymore
because
what if this person
who knows if this person recognizes me
if they know him and they don't like me
i'm just like walking into a stranger's
house
oh there the
the couch is down here in this basement
come along matt
anyway it turned out fine and uh the
person was totally normal and they
didn't
indicate that they'd recognize me at all
so it was completely fine but
i don't know
rolling the dice i suppose all for the
sake of a
a good deal on furniture which means
that i would do it again
zach says matt you're being too hard on
kim she may be wrong on this one topic
but she's really good on vaccines and
other subjects it's not fair to
completely dismiss her and throw her the
trash as you have laurie agrees don't be
too hard on kim i follow you both and
tend to agree with you on this one but
she's a very honest journalist there are
quite a few comments like that saying oh
you're being too hard on
on kim
she was the the woman i responded to the
daily cancellation yesterday
look
there are topics
where i can disagree with somebody
and but i still respect them
and i could even still
embrace them as a as an ally as the left
would like to say you know as someone
someone who could still be on my side
generally in the culture and be very
useful and valuable in the fight there
are there are topics like that where we
can have that kind of disagreement
this is not
one of those topics
i'm sorry
i talked in the beginning about drawing
lines this is a line i draw if you can't
get this right
then i just have no use for you and i
can i cannot respect you i just can't
if you cannot get this right if you
cannot at a minimum understand
why it's wrong to mutilate children chop
their body parts off castrate them
if you can't understand that
or for whatever reason are pretending
that you can't then i i i can't respect
you i'm sorry i can't
um it's it is the most
horrific thing it's one of the most
horrific things a person can support or
advocate for or defend
and
so
you know we have to have some kind of
fundamental shared value system for us
to be on the same side but if your value
system
allows you to defend that then there is
no way our value systems are shared
they're not even in the same universe
so there are there are topics where this
you got to be on the right side of this
one this is basic level stuff okay i
mean i'm not setting the bar very high
i'm really not i'm not saying you have
to agree with me on every single topic i
did but but this if you can't get over
this bar if you somehow trip on the bar
of of you know
not defending the sexual mutilation of
children then i got no use for you
that's it
and i don't care oh she was right about
vaccines i don't care
i just don't
um
that's it
anthony says
even matt walsh even matt walsh has been
i don't know i just saw my name like
that even matt walsh has been effing
programmed to say reach out instead of
contact most annoying phrase ever i do
accept that admonition actually i've
noticed that about myself especially
recently that i say even in emails when
i'm writing an email to somebody
uh i wanted to reach out and i hate
myself when i'm writing it but for some
reason i can't i have been programmed
i'll have an existential crisis while
i'm writing an email and i'll begin it
with oh just wanted to reach out and
then i stop and think no this i don't
want to say this i don't know what else
to say here i i'm sure there's another
way to start an email i don't know how
to do it i
i think it's just
being in an office environment i i've
spent two i've sent too many office
related emails and i and i have been
brainwashed on this one i admit so
you actually are not banned from the
show i will accept that
uh that rebuke humbly
let's see
finally lady jess says hey matt a few
years ago i discovered the perfect
solution to the lost sock problem your
system is way too complicated all you
need to do is this safety pin your socks
together
that's it it's that simple every time
you take your socks off safety pin them
together at the top and then throw them
in the hamper they stay pinned together
through the wash and dry cycle so you
don't end up losing one in the process
how much time do you think i have in my
life you think i have an extra
an extra 47 hours a week that i could
pin that i can
carve out
to sit there safety pinning socks yes
that's how long it would take 47 hours
i've decided what so i'm going to have
like in my closet just a little uh tray
of safety pins and i don't have time for
that okay no one has time for that
it's just that's if i have a sock bag i
can throw them in the sock bag that i
can do because i can do that whole thing
i can do that in one second but the
safety pin i gotta make sure i have a
stock of safety pins i've gotta
pin them together it's this is a long
process
there there's the risk involved that i
that i could you know prick my finger
get blood on the socks it no
not a good solution sorry
so since i showed you uh that ben is
drowning and stuffed wall versus his
team finally found the one true walrus
the official johnny the walrus plushie
displaying him in all his cuddly lovable
glory yet here i said still deprived of
what is rightfully mined i haven't even
seen one of these little walruses let
alone the gargantuan behemoth
uh walrus that is imprisoned somewhere
beyond my reach an undisclosed location
the outpouring of support during
backstage last night was encouraging but
nearly
warmed the walrus-shaped void in my
heart though i your leader suffer in
relative silence complaining only with a
frequency in direct proportion to the
discomfort i've experienced i wish
nothing short of the multitudes of all
versus for my sweet baby so go forth to
dailywire.com
or click the link in the description to
get your very own uh i give you my
blessing
next promo your razor is needed
here at the daily wire we're doing
everything we can to loosen the left's
grip on the culture we're making movies
and documentaries like what is a woman
uh that exposed radical gender ideology
and challenge leftist ideology as well
we're creating kids content that parents
can trust we even have sued the
government over unconstitutional
mandates it's a lot of work and there's
still a long way to go but you can help
with just two simple steps one stop
shaving with your woke razor two start
shaving with your jeremy's razor
and that
is
right here
they did warn me this time so
this is all on me this is on me folks
if you're still not shaving with the
jeremy's razors chances are you're
funding leftist plots we're building
alternatives and the left is betting
their bottom billion dollars that you
won't use those alternatives prove them
wrong shave with jeremy's razors go to
jeremy's razors dot com get your founder
series shave kit today daily wire plus
members get 25 off jeremy's razors shut
up and shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well i'm late to this story but only
because there's so much fake racism in
america that it's hard to keep up so um
and it can become overwhelming uh at
times you know one fake racist is
handled and then
uh only another even faker racist comes
along
we're completely surrounded on all sides
by invisible imaginary races they are
all over the place they're leaving
nooses in nascar garages they're leaving
uses everywhere actually they're writing
notes and leaving on people's cars
they're assaulting obscure television
actors in chicago they're traumatizing
black children at parades and now
they're even attending volleyball games
let's rewind to last friday night
there's a women's volleyball match
between brigham young university and
duke it's at byu
after the game has finished a woman
named
lessa
pamplin
who identified herself as the godmother
of duke volleyball player rachel
richardson took to social media and
announced
that richardson had been the victim of a
dastardly racist incident during the
match now she claimed that every time
richardson served
a racist man in the stands shouted the
n-word at her and she said that after
the match this same man threatened her
physically went up to her and told her
that she better watch her back as she
walks to the team bus
i mean horrible stuff the blaze reports
on what happened next richardson later
claimed in a statement that quote my
fellow african-american teammates and i
were targeted and racially heckled
throughout the entirety of the match the
slurs and comments grew into threats
which caused us to feel unsafe
richardson alleged byu officials were
notified of the alleged threats and and
slurs but failed to take the necessary
steps to stop the unacceptable behavior
and create a safe environment richardson
reiterated many of these comments in an
espn interview on tuesday now naturally
espn took the story and ran and when i
say took it and ran i don't mean in any
sort of journalistic sense okay it's not
like they investigated asked questions
tried to get to the bottom of it they
were not curious about any part of this
story it didn't even strike them as
strange this is the year 2022 and
everybody has a cell phone and yet
nobody caught any of this on film
someone was screaming racial slurs
through the entire match and nobody got
it on camera
it didn't seem curious to them that no
other witnesses came forward to confirm
the story
they didn't notice that this whole thing
sounds exactly like so many other
stories that all and i mean all every
single one turn out to be hoaxes and it
certainly didn't seem odd to them that
some guy in the stands would randomly
decide to completely destroy his own
life permanently
for the sake of insulting some girl on a
volleyball
team
i mean they weren't worried about any of
that
so they breathlessly reported
richardson's claims as if as if they
were objective fact and spent days
screaming with stupid spittle flecked
rage about the incident and when it
comes to stupid spittle flecked rage
nobody can top steven a smith he's the
expert
i'm saying byu you did it
by allowing this to happen and not
addressing it expeditiously not
addressing it with the level of of of
quickness and speed that you should have
addressed it with so now instead of
looking at that fool
that racist bastard that was spewing
that nonsense towards miss rachel
richardson instead of looking at that
person
now we're looking at the university
looking at you of a dereliction of duty
that you put forth because you couldn't
find it in yourself to address it
immediately now it and now we ask the
question well why what took you so long
what would the hesitancy about did you
were you fearful of a reprimand were you
fearful of a backlash if you had decided
as a human being to do the right thing
and protect this young lady and to make
sure she wasn't subjected to this for a
longer period of time what was going on
what was the hesitancy about and since
we're talking about byu now we're
looking at every university
so brave
that racist bastard
who doesn't exist but he's a bastard
steven a smith by the way has been in
broadcasting for decades and still does
not understand how microphones work i
wish someone would explain to him you
don't need to scream we can hear you the
microphone amplifies
your voice
but it wasn't just smith screaming about
this the news media got in on it of
course other athletes and celebrities
spoke out lebron james got in on the
action as expected and then
as also expected the story started to
fall apart uh as we all knew would back
to the blaze it says byu police who
investigated the incident determined
that the fan who was banned for yelling
the racial slurs was not in fact the
person who shouted them the salt lake
tribune reported and further stated that
they had yet to find any evidence that
anyone shot at them at all
when we watched the video uh quote we
when we watched the video we did not
observe that behavior from him byu
police lieutenant george bessendorfer
told the new the newspaper uh buyu
associate athletic director john mcbride
confirmed that university officials came
to the same conclusion he said quote
various byu athletics employees have
been reviewing video from byu tv and
other cameras in the facility that the
volleyball team has access to for film
review this has been ongoing since right
after the match on friday night the
person who was banned was the person
identified by duke as as using racial
search however we have been unable to
find any evidence of that person using
slurs in the match in fact
no evidence has surfaced proving that
anyone shot at racial slurs at all
instead students who attended the game
attest that they never heard any slurs
so
no cell phone video of this slur despite
the fact that it was supposedly being
shouted repeatedly throughout the match
no security camera footage either
and uh and no witnesses a little bit
more on the witnesses the blaze says the
cougar chronicle of byu's student-run
newspaper cited multiple students on the
record who were in the student section
of the game and never heard any slurs
indeed bessendorfer has confirmed that
no student who sat in the section where
the slurs allegedly came from nor anyone
who attended the volleyball match for
that matter has come forward to report
uh that they that who the person was
that they heard it at all even more
importantly best endorphin also said no
one has come forward to say that they
heard the slur being shotted during the
match a police report which the tribune
obtained shows that byu officials placed
a police officer near the duke bench
after they alerted they were alerted to
the racial slurs but no one in that
section identified the person making the
slurs nor did the officer hear any
after police review of the of the video
evidence failed to confirm the person
byu officials banned was the one who
made the slurs bessendorfer said that
the investigation was taken over by byu
officials byu released their own
statement saying quote following friday
night's volleyball game we spent hours
reviewing video of the event to try and
figure out what happened exactly we
understand that the duke players
experience is what matters here they
felt unsafe and hurt and we were unable
to address that during the game in the
manner that was sufficient for that we
truly do apologize
so there are no witnesses no video
evidence no evidence of any kind that
anything like this actually happened
and yet they apologize
i mean you apologize for not addressing
it
if it wasn't happening how could you
address it
but the feelings of a member of a victim
class
must be affirmed and validated no matter
what
even if it didn't happen
she feels like it happened which means
that it might as well have happened
that's the message
this is always the message because what
they cannot do is admit the truth
and here's the truth okay this is the
truth
this kind of racism the kind alleged by
the duke volleyball player
is extremely rare in the united states
virtually non-existent
it has been that way for a long time
it is so rare that most people will
never encounter anything like it
for most people
it is essentially over
now
there are certainly there are certainly
still racism in america much of it is
the kind of racism that we aren't
supposed to acknowledge at all there's
anti-white racism which is embedded into
our system and our institutions there's
anti-black racism too certainly
we just heard an example of it yesterday
with a senate candidate claiming that
black people don't know how to obtain
photo ids that's racist
both anti-white and anti-black racism
come in many other forms as well and
they're often perpetrated by the very
people who call themselves anti-racist
but the sort of anti-black racism that
propels somebody to shout racial slurs
or to leave threatening notes or to hang
nooses around and so on
is for all intents and purposes with
extremely rare potential exception over
and i know that because nearly every
story about an incident of this sort
over the past two decades has been fake
if this sort of thing was common you
would think that at least there would be
more real incidents than fake ones
what's more you'd actually think that
there would be no fake incidents at all
because there'd be no need or appetite
to fake them
there's also something else and this
this is the primary reason why i dismiss
all of these stories out of hand the
minute i the minute i heard about the
duke thing is like that didn't happen i
don't even i don't need to know anything
else it just didn't happen and here's
how i know
human beings are social creatures we
respond to social incentives
there is no social incentive at all for
a white person to go around shouting
racial slurs or hanging nooses or
whatever all of the social incentive
runs the other direction
the consequence for behaving in that way
is the destruction of your entire life
if there was a man in the stands
shouting slurs and all points point all
signs point to
no such man existing
but if he's there we have to assume that
he is insane and suicidal
i mean because it's inconceivable that
somebody who who would just
self-immolate like that for any other
reason
what this means is that even if there
are white racists walking around and i'm
sure there are because there will always
be races of in every race and against
every race but even the actual races are
almost certainly not going to behave in
the ways that the race hoaxers pretend
they behave
now
if you didn't know better
you might think the people who claimed
their advocates for racial equity would
consider this a victory
most people aren't racist
and
most of the ones who are racist
aren't going to say it so say so out
loud
mission accomplished
except that's not the mission they were
trying to accomplish
they want to be
victims
because in our upside-down world
victimization means power
and so if they cannot find the racists
in real life they'll simply invent them
and if you doubt them you're racist too
you cannot deny the racism without being
racist which means by denying it you
validate it
that's the trick
and it's clever i have to admit
but it also means that the race hoaxers
are today finally once and for all
canceled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the
members block with a special guest today
as well hopefully we'll see you there if
not godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you